good motivation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so the
helm on your journey today's message is
how to do yourself over here sighs I
spoke at an education summit for
Microsoft I also spoke at an education
summit for Apple at education from Mike
at the education summit for Microsoft I
would say that 70% of the executives
spent about 70% of their presentations
talking about how to beat Apple at the
Apple education summit a hundred percent
of the executives spent a hundred
percent of their presentations talking
about how to help teachers teach and how
to help students learn one is playing
this way and one is playing that way one
is playing finite and the other one is
playing infinite guess which one gets
frustrated so at the end of my talk at
Microsoft they gave me a gift they gave
me the new Zune when it was a thing and
let me tell you this thing was
spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology I've ever used the user
interface was incredible the design was
spectacular I absolutely loved it
it was easy to use and it was bright and
gorgeous infant it didn't work on iTunes
which is a different problem so I
couldn't use it but but it was amazing
and elegant my god it was elegant so I'm
sitting in the back of a taxi with a
very senior Apple executive sort of
employee number 12 kind of guy and you
know I like to stir pots so I turned him
I said you know Microsoft gave me their
new Zune and in so much better than your
iPod touch and he turned to me and he
said I have no doubt conversation over
because the infinite player understands
sometimes your head and sometimes your
behind sometimes your product is better
and sometimes it's worse the goal isn't
to be the best every day the goal isn't
out to outdo your competition every day
that's a finite construction if I had
said to Microsoft I've got the new iPod
touch and it's so much better than your
Zune they would have said can we see it
what does it do react react react react
finite players play to be bet to beat
the people around them infinite players
play to be better than themselves to
wake up every single day and say how can
we make our company a better version of
itself today than it was yesterday how
can we create a product this week that's
better than the product we created last
week we also have to play the instant
game it's not about being ranked number
one it's not about having more followers
on Twitter than your friends it's not
about outdoing anyone it's about how to
outdo yourself it's not about selling
more books or getting more Ted views
than somebody else it's about how to
make sure that the work that you're
producing is better than your work you
produced before you are your competition
and that is what ensures you stay in the
game the longest and that is what
ensures you find joy because the joy
comes not from comparison but from
advancement so if these are enemies is
actually good day I think enemies in
pushing to be better do more go stronger
it doesn't mean have to copy that but I
think they put
to see a better version of you you know
Tupac was better because of biggie the
Yankees are better because of the Red
Sox Apple is better because Microsoft
exists
you know I'm better because of people
like Gary Vaynerchuk and Grant Cardone
and all the other guys from unique
opinions as well it doesn't mean that we
copy them right you know the way they
Gary winning the smoothest speeches
through his blog you know daily people
hauling around if I was just copying
human stable business the way to win I
need to do exactly that I'm going to
lose if you look at your competition
today I'm just going to be a copycat
that's when you lose because you can't
tell them that right I can't else Gary
Gary and Gary and SSM it's just not
possible right if you look at your
competition just saying I'm a copycat
we've lost already
but the look at that exceeds they're
growing they're beating you know there's
they're getting more market share
they're getting more customers because
they're getting more subscribers that
can push you to do better
you know sprinter is do better when they
have people behind them we're also good
if you're constantly the best in your
field that you have no competition then
it is in place to get lazy to relax and
so think how many enemy is a good thing
but I definitely realize we need to try
to help do yourself every single day I
look at myself with my competition look
at my videos from last week and say how
do I do better how do I get better yes I
want to inspire me like us Les Brown or
a court of robbers and learn through
them and their skills and their
abilities and not be then Butler
composed to be that version of me
and I want to be better than I was last
week and it was before before before and
you may not only be different from week
to week being exactly see
different with more time penological
come out of my videos five six years ago
and say wow so much has changed you know
I'm still the same guy I sell the same
parts of you but my abilities have grown
because I practice we've done five
thousand videos raising you got to get
into it as something if you've done it
five thousand times you know if you're
practicing really neat efficiently you
better get good at anything you could
try and five thousand times and so I
think it's really important that you can
look up to other people you can look up
to your rivals potentially and say these
people are pushing me to do better to be
more of myself to work harder to grind
it out more the hustle more is I'm not
going to use external people as my
barometer success because if I'm only
looking at less bran or Rickon Bala
maybe you'll never get to Les Brown of
them don't use doesn't beat you down
because it kick forward but in I want to
compare myself to Hollywood last week
because if you're only comparing
yourself when you are here to start
somebody else's lives with somebody
else's end not a fair fight as you can
use it as inspiration but tactically
to practically on a day-to-day basis
competing and beatings out doing
yourself is super important so I don't
think it's one over the other I think
you take the best of both tests you can
tell the best version of yourself so the
question is not curious what have you
done recently else do your stuff if
you're looking back a week a month a
year what if you got a really good at
that you can work so good at before have
a little bit of a bribe show some love
for yourself have a little bravado it's
okay this I want to see it come out
leave it down the comments below really
do see you again I also want to give a
quick chatter - Jonathan's ballgame
charges making still watch your figure
if accomplished my book here one work is
taking a picture with it posted it on
Twitter with often see and I'm really
thankful for this report and I'm glad
that you enjoyed but so thank you guys
so much for watching
I
see what you opt to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much loved
and as you get far more a for another
shot of its best
[Music]
how many times have you ever heard the
phrase you are perfect just as you are
any her development you know what you're
perfect just as you are you are so
perfect just as you are well you know
what you are not you are not perfect
just as you are you are perfect but
you're not complete this is the thing
and this is what I mean by it and I
people going to go away you mean I'm
what are you trying to say I got to
change I got to change somebody else yes
yes you need to change everybody
everybody out there needs to change we
are designed for chain nothing in this
world stays the same you are either
getting better or you are getting worse
let me describe something to you when I
say you are perfect but you are not
complete let's say this building I mean
if I look at the blueprints but it's
building it's the blueprints for this
building before it was built or perfect
everything was in his right place
everything was great but could I walk in
it could I do anything did I have a
building no why
it wasn't complete when they framed up
this building and puts wood and metal
and all this stuff but they didn't do
the floor didn't do the electrical was
it perfect yes it was perfect but it
wasn't completion you I like this
building you are perfect in every way
but you're just not done you're not done
and you know what anybody is trying to
tell you don't try to change me yeah now
no one should try to change you but you
have to change yourself you are you owe
it to everyone to change yourself into a
better person into a better human being
that's what you have to do you are
perfect but you just not complete so
when you look at yourself look at
yourself at that building and it's
framed up and everything is in its right
place but you're just not done I want to
tell you that so anybody who's trying to
tell you that I'm perfect just the way I
am is not trying to
and guess what you know and it's not
worth it
you're a half done building who wants to
live in a building with no roof nobody
and I'm just trying to break it down to
you that you hear these catchphrases you
hear this stuff all the time but
everybody just takes it and says oh yeah
I'm perfect just the way I am and you
don't train and your life doesn't change
and you don't think it's better for you
and you wonder what's happening and
everything is crumbling around you hey
I'm guilty Terry Crews is guilty then I
realize wait a minute wait a minute I'm
not perfect just the way I am I have to
be perfected I am perfect but I am not
complete at the end of the day it's
called the music business so you've got
to continue always find ways to better
your business it's kind of like Apple
you know if he stayed on on a laptop
then what would he be know what is what
is Steve Jobs and the whole team come up
with Touch iPad iPod now iCloud it's
always finding ways to get better and
that's the way I look at it your music I
said well now I can just go from rapping
with everybody neighborhood to the whole
world
and it works and everybody's doing now I
gotta figure out the next movement and I
gotta figure out my neck I some I don't
write down goes and go get them you know
I know a lot of people do that but I'll
just kind of try to outdo myself I'll do
my last I'll do and although this is a
competition in every sport navigate the
industry as a sport because if it's
numbers and its money and its
achievements and Championships et cetera
et cetera you know I'm only really in
competition with myself you know
although it is you know a fun
competition to look over and see what's
at home in Tennessee
you know today for me is all about
bettering me better in the music I'm a
veteran my fan experience bettering my
business bettering myself as a man and
higher and the truth is there's a lot of
one accomplished in the music industry
there's a there's a lot of one
accomplished
accomplished as a businessman you know I
haven't done a lot of those things that
although I have done a lot I feel like
I'm just getting my feet wet and the
ceiling is very high for me